the storm coming
load up I've been waiting for you
wait what what happened to the scared
Sarah Connor of my youth now she's a
full-blown dragon toting badass what
have you done to my precious terminator
it's eyelines Genesis The Terminator
series has been going amazing since 1984
until about 1993 then the other movies
happened but the latest movie Terminator
Genisys isn't exactly a reboot just
because they started the entire thing
over they've altered the timelines in a
way never done before in this series and
it's still heavily connected to the old
movies this is an example of one of the
most complicated timelines in film
history unless you've seen prime that
movie will make your freaking head
explode man you'll need a sponge to
clean it up and gets ugly I'm Gabe Howe
writer and if you just want an
explanation of what the heck is going on
in Terminator then come with me if you
want to have that explanation I think I
messed that up this is hashtag news
okay we got to move fast because there's
a lot to explain and understand here and
to really get it we got to go back
that's loss alright how do we get to
this new bizarro Genesis timeline
I'll explain terminator despite what you
may think actually doesn't get too mixed
up an alternate timeline more often than
not the movies are all in the same
timeline with only one real exception
that was dealt with mostly off screen
which is why this timeline change is
such a big deal not only does it change
everything in a really confusing way but
it doesn't ways that expects you to
follow imagine that okay so let's start
describing the timeline established in
Terminator 1 in 1984 there's a young
waitress lady named Sarah Connor she's
gonna have a baby named John in 1985 con
down related to her a while later in
Cyberdyne creates Skynet an evil program
slash robot hivemind that hacks the
world's noose and has us all nuking each
other everything gets blown up and there
are only a few survivors Sarah Connor
and her son John Connor will make it
through this Sarah has trained John to
be a great military leader and way later
in 2029 he's leading surviving humans
and is actually about to successfully
defeat Skynet and it's robot army Skynet
knowing it's about to lose everything
uses its ace up its sleeve a time-travel
device it sends one of its machines a
Terminator t800 the Arnold Terminator we
all know and love back to 1984 to kill
Sarah Connor and prevent John Connor
from ever being born that way the
machines would win since the humans
would have no leader so future John
Connor knowing this is happening decides
to send one of his best soldiers Kyle
Reese also back to 1984 to protect his
mom Sarah he doesn't send a whole army
because whoever goes has no way of
getting back they're gonna have to live
out the rest of the 80s that poor poor
man also because sending a lone hero
lets us have a classic 80s love scene oh
yeah look at his hands
grabbing each other so yes there is some
weird stuff going on in this timeline
because it turns out when Kyle and Sarah
hook up resulting baby becomes John
Connor who is the same guy who's sent
him back in time in the first place to
bang his mom and become his dad I think
it's safe to say John Connor has daddy
issues now well you could think that
this is the start of an alternate
timeline where John Connor now has a new
dad from the future it's actually not
because Terminator time-travel is kind
of weird that way it's called a
predestination paradox meaning all the
events in this timeline have always
happened like it was fake so Kyle Reese
was always John Connors dad and John
Connor is a badass warrior in the future
only because his mom knew to give him
battle training since she now knows what
happens in that future now if you really
feel that this logic doesn't make
perfect scientific sense I would counter
that with
you just got to deal with it so yada
yada the Terminator gets destroyed and
so does Kyle Reese but all of that was
taking place in a timeline where those
things have actually always happened so
at the end of the movie nothing has
really changed and we're still headed
toward the 1997 Judgment Day in the
future war with the machines so
Terminator 2 when that happens we're
actually still on that same timeline
from Terminator 1 Sarah Connor is kind
of psycho now which is what happens when
you tell people your baby daddy was from
the future and your son is our only hope
against the machines
so she's locked in a mental hospital
John Connor is an angsty punk tween
being raised by foster parents now this
movie is awesome and has a badass
villain the t1000 and a great twist
where the future human resistance
reprograms a t800 and makes it a good
guy but none of that stuff affects the
timeline really because even though
Skynet got desperate and sent back more
terminators than we thought spoiler
alert the good guys still win and
Skynet's attempts don't change the
timeline any however the secondary story
in Terminator 2 where they decide to
prevent Judgment Day by destroying
Cyberdyne slash Skynet in this main
inventor guy miles Dyson blows himself
up with click actually does change the
timeline this is the beginning of a
brand new timeline where life should be
good for everyone right wrong Terminator
3 picks up on the new timeline Linda
Hamilton Sarah Connor is dead because
she got leukemia it's a very serious
type of leukemia where movie producers
don't want to work with you anymore
and John Connor is now an angsty adult
t3 is a bit of a ripoff of t2 with a
good terminator and a bad Terminator
fighting over John Connor but the bad
guy is now a hot lady Terminator so I
guess it's totally different good job
producers apparently a different version
of Skynet was still being worked on and
this time the US government is behind it
so good luck stopping that one with all
that Republicans and Democrats and
Congress and do you know anything about
politics not a thing the movie ends with
alternate Skynet causing alternate
Judgment Day except now it's 2004 but
we're still on the second time on
Terminator 4 what sorry it's not
actually about time travel at all so I'd
say we could skip it entirely except
it's worth reminding everyone that this
is the movie that caused the new John
Connor Christian Bale to have his epic
freakout the deaf are you doing can we
get some food professionals in their
place are you an American I don't I'm
trying to figure out what exactly I am
so I hope you've kept up with us so far
because that's just the old movies now
the storm Terminator Genisys in terms of
the timeline we actually start this
movie out in a pretty neutral place the
filmmakers kind of purposely kept it
vague as to which timeline we were on
which works since both of the timelines
have the future of war with machines so
this Terminator saga that we watched
through 1984 past the 1990s is finally
caught up on the other end in 2029 when
the Terminator and Kyle Reese are first
sent back except this time Kyle Reese
looks less 80s and more like diehard son
now here's where everything gets super
messy when Kyle Reese goes back to 1984
we should theoretically be watching the
first movie play out which it actually
starts to but then some major
differences occur first a t-1000 is
waiting for Kyle Reese even though that
never happened in the original 1984 also
the t800 that was sent back to kill
Sarah started out on the same path but
suddenly he gets his bare ass handed to
him by another t800 who conveniently
looks the same age that Arnold
Schwarzenegger does in real life and
even weirder things happen Kyle Reese is
supposed to go back in time to save
Sarah Connor but she's not a scared
waitress anymore instead she's a full-on
badass and she saves Kyle Reese plus she
knows all about terminators and t1000 s
and messed up timelines so how did all
this get so effed up well Skynet sent
yet another terminator back to kill
Sarah Connor in 1973 before the first
movie even took place
this means the filmmakers have gone back
to the timeline of the first two good
movies then went even further back 11
years before them and changed the entire
timeline way back there so that is how
we got the alternate timeline number
three where all this weird stuff in
Terminator Genisys lives and here's the
biggest deal because it starts before
any of the movies take place it has
effectively erased the Terminator
history that we've ever known
all of it gosh this move might feel a
little familiar because Star Trek and
x-men Days of Future past just pulled
the same move of sending an existing
character back in time and changing the
timeline from the beginning in order to
start the whole series over but keep it
connected to the originals and Wow
Hollywood will literally change the
fabric of time and space to replace old
familiar faces with sexy new actors this
new timeline that starts in 1973 has a
major plot hole Sara survived this
assassination attempt because someone
sent back a different t800 to protect
her and that Terminator actually raised
her which is why she's such a badass
when the new 1984 comes around I mean if
you were raised by a jacked-up killer
robot you'd probably be a badass too or
guess at least emotionally unavailable
but who sent this good terminator back
to protect Sarah in 1973 the movie
actually doesn't tell us yeah I know I
know that said I think they're purposely
leaving this information out to leave
some mystery for the two corporately
mandated sequels that they have planned
the film rights revert back to James
Cameron in a few years how else does the
new timeline differ from the original
one well the Judgment Day that in the
first timeline was going to happen in
1997 has now been pushed all the way
back to 2017 we actually don't know how
that happened since the old inventor
dude who blew himself up to stop the
1997 version remember click boom is
actually still alive and well and is
actually his son in 2017 that's creating
this new version of Skynet called
Genesis to happen I'm just glad we're
keeping the apocalypse in the family you
know I mean also here's where it all
gets a bit cute Genesis is basically
Siri and it's all a bit too clever play
on how much we care too much about our
cell phones now and social identity is a
mixed emotion gay but oh sorry ah
something about the characters Oh also
having the characters build a time
machine so that they can jump forward to
2017 seems more like a convenient way to
get your cute new Sarah Connor to live
in the modern day and not have to make
all these new films with their weird
he's hair so at the end of the day the
timeline is brand new and not at all one
that we've seen before and the way they
got there is through some tricky Skynet
scheming in the deeper past if that
doesn't make sense remember its
terminator subscribe if you found this
breakdown helpful if you want to see
some more movie explaining or me
acapella movie soundtracks leave a
comment what you think of this movie by
the way a worthy successor if you
haven't seen it we actually haven't
spoiled too much so go watch it but
definitely watch terminator 1 & 2 first
because even though they're technically
erased now movie is filled with tons of
references to them that make the movie a
lot better and if you're too lazy to do
that watch our other video that shows
every reference and easter egg in the
film and how about that charming host
huh yeah go watch it I'm capable writer
and I really don't have any concern
about the future and alternate timelines
because I'm close personal friends with
Arnold Schwarzenegger you think you
could plug gates channel Gabe's channel
6's is not one of my visions parameters
right of course why would it be when we
get some pants on roll the videos of me
they're rolling good you're talking over
them Oh
and